I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark I love my eyes I
didn't miss anything
that's what what time
welcome back to my hilarious 'ti series
covering really crappy video game movies
I've already talked about do a Dead or
Alive House of the Dead and now we're
moving on to doom because I have all of
the video games that could have become a
movie doom got made we don't need a
Metal Gear Solid movie we don't need a
Metroid Prime movie we don't need a
Legend of Zelda movie we'll make movies
like doom because those are easy to make
I mean really think about it almost
every video game - movie adaptation is
based off of a very simple game safe for
maybe the Tomb Raider movies
Dead or Alive a fighting game based off
of jiggly women House of the Dead an
arcade game with zombies why are these
the games that are being made into
movies because they don't take much
effort that's why so doom to this day is
still a very popular FPS game we've had
a new incarnation of it fairly recently
but back in the day this was a very
simple game that broke some new
boundaries and people were impressed by
it and people enjoyed playing it so of
course now we have a movie starring the
rock and Karl Urban and as this movie
progresses you can just tell that they
are struggling to figure out how to make
it a movie it's like there's one scene
that we'll get to later in the review
where you're like okay this is why they
wanted to make this movie because they
just wanted to tribute the game in some
way every other scene is just a horribly
derivative mashup of aliens and predator
so this movie opens up with some
scientists who are in the middle of some
incredible trauma and just count how
many times this guy blinks starts a
comic classified research order by ID
six six to seven
we've had a level-five bridge implement
quarantine procedures immediately
implement quarantine procedures now so
as I said the rock and Karl Urban are
both in this movie that's right Hobbes
from Fast and the Furious and Judge
Dredd himself are in this movie that is
potentially awesome that could be really
great they really don't do much with
with these guys unfortunately they
basically spend the entire movie
sneaking around we'll talk more about
that soon so I guess we're in the Year
2046 that's a very interesting 2046
handheld game you've got there yeah
you're holding it the wrong way buddy
and why are these guys playing baseball
so dangerously it's like somebody's
gonna get seriously hurt before they
have to go on this death-defying mission
oh so the blinky guy sends a distress
signal and our heroes go out into the
fray this movie really reminds me of
predator in so many ways my girlfriend I
said you know I'd like a little pussy
she said me too I just big as a house
you know kid it's funny
a couple days ago I asked Sarge for a
little pussy the next day brought you on
the d-team I mean the fact that both
movies feature a joke about female
anatomy before the characters go out
into the fray that's just one thing I
mean there's a lot more we're gonna talk
about so everybody gets zapped somewhere
Galaxy Quest style then we get a very
awkward flashback explaining why this
character who's just been introduced has
been cut in half because we really need
to know everything and we really should
have flashbacks to show us everything
because we all know the best form of
storytelling is flashbacks excessive
ones preferably hello everyone I bet
you're wondering how I got here today
well I'll let you know well I just came
over and sat right down in this chair
picked up my notepad and got ready to
talk about doom so the guy who killed
Bruce Wayne's parents is in this film
and he is a creepy ass motherfucker
100 level 5 quarantine so I am just
gonna have to strip-search you girls oh
that Bob wonder level 5 quarantine so
I'm just gonna have to strip or sergeant
and this is one of those movies that
falls into the worst trap ever for
scientist characters it just makes every
character just spout out all these
technobabble words that mean nothing to
us and in fact mean nothing to anybody
really is just supposed to be like smart
words archaeology genetics and weapons
research magnesium chromium LED dolly
shot crane shot crash zoom pan match cut
fade to black like it's like that it's
just me spouting off filmmaking terms
and that's it and right around here is
where this movie becomes the sneaking
movie everyone just starts to sneak
around the facility it's very
reminiscent of aliens it just doesn't
have the focus that James Cameron gave
to that film this movie has a lot of
people sneaking around an eerily dark
facility and there's some serious shit
going on somewhere in this facility and
so you feel a little on edge but the
movie really is just trying to recreate
things we've seen in other films and it
thinks that just by showing us the
aesthetics
these things for some reason the movies
going to be that good so they find the
blinky guy who proceeds to rip off his
ear and bettan he didn't have a very
good day and this is where I started to
notice the lighting in this movie is
actually fairly awful it's not like
you're watching something that's ugly
it's just far too dim you can't really
focus on it and I watched this movie on
blu-ray so that's saying something so
there's a character in this movie that
takes his religion very seriously and if
he takes God's name in vain he actually
cuts himself on his wrist deeply and
draws blood now I get it but like you're
a soldier you're in the middle of like
this thing you want to be at the top of
your game you don't want to be slicing
holes in yourself wait till you get home
or something so they find this zombie
and they ask those a'm be a question sir
okay yeah I don't think he's okay I
think it's pretty fucked so in what is
becoming a tradition in all of my
hilarious ATI's I must point out films
that have awful ADR moments because it
seems like every hilarious 'ti I ever do
there's always a terrible audio dubbed
moment and this film has one for the
rock everybody on me watch her goddamn
pudding everybody on me watch her
goddamn pudding everybody on me watch
your goddamn pudding in this movie at
this point you're just like at some
point is it gonna be anything other than
them sneaking around it takes them
forever to find anything it takes
forever for anything to happen this
movie should just been called sneak
forget about doom why is this film even
called doom because the video game is
called doom I mean at least Dead or
Alive is about the Dead or Alive
Tournament House of the Dead there's a
house on this island and there's zombies
so House of the Dead I guess Super Mario
Brothers has Super Mario Brothers
despite the fact of what most Porto
Rican the other ones English and they
should never be brothers but they're not
Italian in the movie and that's really
dumb that's my rant on Super Mario
Brothers honestly it's really just like
hey the game is called doom so we'll
call the movie doom why is this called
doom it should have been called sneak or
better yet aliens predator rip
movie based off a video game called doom
so a creature attacks these guys and
surprisingly there isn't that much CGI
in this movie for a while it's actually
like a realistic creature despite the
fact that it's such dim lighting and you
can't really tell what's going on that
is something I was proud of I was like
oh yeah you guys did the real stuff yay
practical oh right we got something to
look forward to here besides the rocks
stare and of course what would any movie
with a bunch of men sneaking around a
facility be without a dick joke you know
do God that secretly you have a big
heart oh yeah and that's not the only
secret big thing I got one of the
biggest disappointments for me about
this movie is actually the rocks
character usually I really like the
rocking movies and this is one of the
few movies where I'm just like if I
don't really feel him he has nothing to
him he's just this guy who's like the
rock and he walks around a facility and
eventually just starts going insane
which we'll get into in a minute but
there's nothing to his character he's
just the rock and it's like they just
took someone famous and said put him on
screen put them in this weird
environment and it'll look like aliens
and predator so it'll be good so
everybody gets evacuated from the
facility and this is something I really
genuinely do like about this movie I
like the feel of isolation I love sci-fi
movies where characters are isolated in
a strange environment that's really cool
I wish this movie could have been great
it's so many fun little things that
could have made this movie actually
really fun this honestly is like the
perfect movie that would come on the
sci-fi channel Friday night at 2:30 a.m.
that's the perfect place for this movie
that's what this movie exists and if you
see the movie in that circumstance you
might have fun watching it as far as
characterization goes in this film Karl
Urban is probably the best character
everyone else is just a quirk you know
what I mean everyone else just has like
a thing about them that makes them a
character I guess because they all have
their things the one guy cuts himself if
you says God's name in vain everyone has
their own little things about them to
make them interesting people but it's
just a quirk I mean we were talking
about similarities to predator there's
even a character in this movie named
Mack
talk to me talk to me back back mad so
eventually the revelation comes forth
that the creatures in this movie were at
one point in time people possibly the
scientists that inhabited this area so
everyone starts freaking out even more
and the rock eventually finds The BFG no
not the Big Friendly Giant the big
fucking gun it's like they had to have
it you know and that's fine I that's not
I have no problem that I haven't that's
awesome that's fine
that should be in this movie it was just
like link opening a crate and finding it
it was like this big epic scene around
finding this thing
I do however love the rocks reaction to
his new gun and just when you think
maybe the movie was starting to become
its own movie we can't let them get to
the surface if a breeze kill it bleeds
we can kill it
Wow so I guess the creatures start
disabling the computers in this facility
making it more difficult for everybody
to get around because as I said the
creatures were scientists at one point
now they've turned into creatures I just
want them to cut to that happening like
the creatures later I remember there so
I know I do i memorize all right oh
that's not the water I know I remember
this mmm uh I did I just want to see
that in this movie so as I alluded to
earlier the rock at this point just
starts losing his mind he just goes
crazy he starts killing members of his
own team just because they asked
questions holy shit mutinous
insurrection is punishable by death it's
not going to be my last he just goes
nuts and now we have like a war I guess
between Karl Urban and the rock in this
movie doom 2005 has one very special
thing about it it features possibly the
most abrupt character shift I've ever
seen in the movie The Rock just loses
his mind all of a sudden goes rogue and
gratefully for the screenwriters a
creature shows up very fast so they
don't have to explain what just happened
that is such a movie cliche for a
terrible script oh boy we don't know
what's happening just just throw
something at the screen and everyone
will forget about it right so it becomes
clear that our hero in this movie is
Karl Urban Rosamund Pike then gives him
an injection and then we get the scene
we have a long unbroken take that is
supposed to look like a first-person
shooter moment from the video game
completely true
spurred over to the movie and it's hard
to tell if it's supposed to be hilarious
or not because there are far too many
funny moments
it should have been just a really fun
moment but unfortunately it looks
terrible
there's nothing convincing about it it
genuinely feels like a cutscene right
out of a videogame it doesn't feel like
it belongs in this movie it feels like
the studio just went hey you got to have
an FPS moment and they went okay well
we'll just kind of throw it in here uh
it genuinely feels like one of those
throw everything at the wall and see
what sticks moments and because once
again the screenwriters seem to have
completely lost any sense of whatever
story they were trying to tell the rock
shows up and I guess they're just gonna
fight now he's got a bite mark and he's
changing and they're going to have a big
battle I guess and holy shit this is
when the movie gets amazing
the rock turns into a fucking monster he
look at that it's the greatest thing I
have ever seen in my life
I had no idea this was in this movie I
just popped it in I had never seen it
before
I didn't know Karl Urban or Rosamund
Pike was in this movie I started
watching it I was just blown away the
rock turns in to a fricking monster look
the movie didn't have much going forward
already it was basically sneaked around
quietly the movie but like at least it
was a movie you could kind of watch it
and accept the stupidity as soon as the
rock goes nuts the movie just loses all
sense of whatever it was and becomes
insanity it's kind of entertaining them
so the fight is over and the movie just
kind of ends it's like the film was an
okay guilty pleasure type movie you'd
find on the sci-fi channel in the middle
of the night and then it just lost all
sense of character motivation or
storytelling of any kind doom isn't that
great I think most people already knew
that it's a game that really doesn't
have to be a movie if you really just
want to watch the FPS scene you can
probably find it on YouTube somewhere
the rest of the movie is just like a
thing that's like built around a very
flimsy idea that's essentially just a
ripoff of predator and aliens but it
does have the rock as a monster so I
mean that's a major plus for anything
guys I've had a great time talking about
crappy video game movies leading up to
Assassin's Creed look forward to that
review very soon and I'm excited to
bring another series of movie reviews to
you very soon I'm having a great time
doing this you guys are the best and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes